We do have a discussion forum where more than
twenty one thousand of our viewers and listeners
are now subscribed. It's all free. David Pakman
dot com slash. Read it. A few posts and topics
of interest that I spotted this morning that
I do want to discuss with you. Users Steal
014 posted. The White House has announced
Trump will resume Corona virus press briefings.
Why was there a hiatus and why are they all
of a sudden coming back? So essentially the
answer to both questions is sort of the same,
except the perspective was changed. The hiatus
started because the White House wanted to
portray Corona virus as being over. So one
of the ways to portray coronavirus being over
is saying we no longer need to do daily White
House press briefings. The press briefings
were also doing damage in the sense that at
one of the last ones before the break, Donald
Trump wondered out loud about injecting hitting
the body, as he says, with isopropyl alcohol
and bleach to treat coronavirus disaster.
And so the idea was, let's stop the briefings
in order to help Trump by pretending Corona
virus is over. That didn't work and the first
wave never ended.
And now we are actually back to over a thousand
deaths a day. We are at 60, 70000 cases a
day, maybe in the direction of 100000 cases
a day. So for the same reason, because things
aren't going well, Trump is going back to
try to improve his approval. He stopped the
press briefings to try to improve his approval.
He's now restarting them to try to improve
his approval. And it has been sort of a different
Trump that has shown up saying, you know,
masks are important. Taking the mask out of
his pocket, which he keeps with them as a
prop all the time, now saying it may get worse
before it gets better. A very different tone
than we have 15 cases, which will soon be
zero. We now have, by the way, four point
one million cumulative cases. So I don't know
whether this will make an impact at this point.
It may be too little, too late, but the reason
that there was a hiatus is the same reason
that the White House corona virus press briefings
are now back. Also from the David Pakman shows
show sub Reddit user Katie all the time posted.
What happens if many refuse the Corona virus
vaccine? Should it come out saying right now,
Dr. Foushee says getting herd immunity might
not be possible due to our anti vax anti science
and anti authority sentiment. Unfortunately,
he is right. You're going to have to convince
people who may normally be pro vaccine.
But are scared. The vaccine was rushed through.
This is a serious issue. I mean, there's no
other way around it. The United States is
uniquely dropping the ball on corona virus.
And it's not that anti VAX is only present
in the United States, but there are some big
on claims of it here. And the level of immunity
you need to get herd immunity varies based
on how contagious something is. So, for example,
measles is so contagious. I think it has a
reproduction value and are not of. I think
it's somewhere between 16 and 18. And when
something has a 16 to 18, Arnott, you need
like 95 percent of the population to be immune
to be vaccinated in order to have herd immunity.
Now, corona virus is not as contagious as
measles, of course, but at Corona virus is
level of a spread ability of contagion. The
estimates are you need about 70 percent immunity.
Now we're only at like one, two percent from
people who have recovered from the virus.
And we don't even know how long that immunity
lasts. At this point. So you are going to
need a lot of people to get the vaccine. And
some significant portion has already said
they probably won't. So I don't have a solution.
But this user on our sub Reddit is correctly
pointing out that we may be up against a real
problem here if and when the vaccine is available
and if and when we determine that the vaccine
creates a sturdy immune response, the anti
VAX movement and some people who are just
going to be worried because of, hey, this
vaccine was developed quicker than any other
vaccine, maybe it's not safe, even though,
of course, safety trials are like the first
hurdle that it has to get through. I don't
have an answer, unfortunately, Katy, but that
that is likely to be a problem. Join the discussion
at David Pakman dot com slash r e d d eyeteeth